[Música]
con una votación de cinco a favor y
cuatro en contra la corte constitucional
en colombia determinó ampliar el aborto
libre y legal hasta la semana 24 sin
embargo esta decisión no se trata de la
eliminación del delito del aborto del
código penal colombiano está práctica
seguirá siendo castigada luego de las 24
semanas cuando no se trate de las tres
causales ya existentes en las que se
pueda abortar por malformación del feto
abuso sexual a la mujer y riesgo en la
vida de la madre el aborto es la cuarta
causa de mortalidad materna en el país y
se calcula que los 400.000 abortos que
se realizan en colombia al año menos del
10% son llevados a cabo en instituciones
sanitarias con garantías para ello
entonces quiero saludar a paula ávila
guillena directora ejecutiva de women's
y cuadris sanders gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de francia
24 paula le pregunta entonces la
importancia de esta medida para la mujer
y personas gestantes en colombia
muchísimas gracias por la invitación y
pues claramente este es un fallo
histórico no sólo por las estadísticas
que ya se mencionaron de la cantidad de
mujeres que estaban siendo obligadas a
recurrir a abortos inseguros y las
consecuencias que tendría para sant en
día para su salud y su vida
tradicionalmente porque hay un promedio
de 400 mujeres criminalizadas al año en
colombia por por no poder acceder por
acceder a aborto por decidir sobre sus
propios cuerpos y lo que sabemos de
estos datos es que la mayoría de las
mujeres y de las niñas que andan que
terminaban criminalizadas o en
hospitales pertenecían a grupos
vulnerables a niñas y mujeres y personas
gestantes que ya se encontraban de una
otra forma desprotegidas por el estado y
pues esta decisión lo que está haciendo
es de una u otra forma nivelar el piso y
diciendo que todas tenemos los mismos
derechos en colombia y que el aborto
deja de ser un privilegio ahora paula
porque se había demorado tanto tomar
esta decisión porque hoy en día todavía
hay tanta resistencia a legalizar el
aborto
creo que parte de eso es porque es
culturalmente y históricamente todavía
existe esta idea de que las mujeres no
somos capaces de decirnos sobre nuestro
propio cuerpo de qué pasaría si nos dan
la libertad de tomar decisiones a
nosotras todavía existe esta creencia
que es mejor que un juez o que los
congresistas tomen las decisiones por
las mujeres cuando en realidad lo que
sabemos es que la decisión de abortar de
una persona no va a cambiar
independiente de si es legal o no
entonces estos son cambios que se están
dado que se están dando recientemente
durante 20 años en latinoamérica no hubo
ningún movimiento en términos de
legislaciones y en los últimos
legislaciones relacionadas con temas de
aborto pero en los últimos
dos años hemos visto argentinas
en diciembre del 2020 en méxico en
octubre del año pasado y ahora colombia
entonces creo que ya está existiendo una
tendencia que es reconocer la autonomía
de las mujeres usted hablaba también
paula de que con esta ley el aborto
entonces ya no va a ser un privilegio
pero yéndonos a la práctica que digamos
que siempre es más difícil que el papel
no cree que va a ser fácil que esto se
aplique en la medida de lo posible a
todos los territorios de colombia sobre
todo en los territorios de difícil
acceso a las rurales donde también estas
personas necesitan esta atención médica
paula
pues la implementación de las leyes
siempre es un reto sobre todo en la
parte rural eso lo hemos visto en el
caso de argentina que paso la ley en
diciembre del 2020 pero definitivamente
el hecho de tener una sentencia tan
amplia como la de la corte una sentencia
a una de las más progresistas que existe
en el mundo y definitivamente la más
progresista en américa latina va a
facilitar esa implementación tenemos que
esperar a leer el fallo completo con
respecto a las órdenes que específicas
queda para la regulación y eso va a ser
súper importante pero considero que los
lineamientos que ya conocemos de la
corte son lo suficientemente amplios
precisamente para ampliar y para
asegurar esa implementación o sea en vez
de dar unos lineamientos muy chiquitos y
muy específicos la corte está dando unos
lineamientos amplios para facilitar esa
implementación en la zona rural en las
zonas rurales
tradicionalmente hay algo que cambio en
colombia que va a facilitar la
implementación y es ver las personas que
estaban en la calle celebrando ver esas
celebraciones o esas manifestaciones
visto en los últimos meses alrededor de
este caso es algo que no habíamos visto
en colombia antes entonces cuando ya
existe además del cambio legal una de
criminalización social ayuda muchísimo a
la implementación sin embargo paula la
iglesia y otros sectores de la sociedad
que están en contra de esta práctica
esta legalización es del aborto que ya
como como estamos comentando la corte
constitucional colombiana pues lo avaló
hasta las 24 semanas ellos quieren
imponer y apelar esta decisión es
realmente tienen medidas legales y
pudieran tumbar este fallo de la corte
constitucional
no la corte constitucional es el máximo
tribunal que existe en colombia y es el
tribunal encargado de evaluar si hay
leyes o no que están de acuerdo con la
constitución colombiana y cuando hay un
fallo de la corte realmente no existen
recursos de apelación contra ese fallo
entonces en este momento por más de que
digan que van a intentar hacer cosas
realmente ilegalmente hablando lo que
deben hacer es respetar la decisión de
la corte y entender que lo que está
haciendo la corte es protegiendo la
salud y la vida de las niñas mujeres y
las personas gestantes en colombia y que
las las razones por las cuales estos
países han cambiado las leyes
recientemente es es porque ya se ha
comprobado que el prohibir o
criminalizar el aborto no reduce los
números de aborto si realmente lo que
estas organizaciones quieren es reducir
los números de aborto entonces deberían
tratar de pedir por leyes de educación
sexual anticonceptivos para todos y por
supuesto atención aborto y post aborto y
apoyo a las mate unidades deseadas ya
para finalizar nuestra conversación o
paula eso es un ejemplo para otros
países de américa latina' digamos cómo
está la región frente a este tema
pues sí es definitivamente un ejemplo
colombia es el tercer país en dos años
que legaliza el aborto argentina en
diciembre como dije cambió sus leyes
para permitir el aborto en las primeras
14 semanas en méxico en octubre la
suprema corte decidió que no se podía
enviar a una mujer presa por abortar
ahora a nivel estatal cada estado está
tratando de implementar esta decisión
pero definitivamente la de colombia es
una de las es la más avanzada de la
región
y entra a hacer parte de un círculo
pequeño de países en latinoamérica
porque antes teníamos a cuba y uruguay
pero el sistema está cambiando y ahorita
que pienso que esta marea verde que se
formó en argentina que llegó a méxico y
ahora colombia es imparable creo que los
ojos del mundo están en chile que está
por un proceso similar e igual en
república dominicana que si bien está
pensando en solo aceptar las tres
causales está avanzando y está
considerando avanzar en este tema pues
pablo muchísimas gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en este espacio
de france 24 llamado
américa un gran abrazo
muchísimas gracias a ustedes un abrazo